600 pound line that show is unbelievable
like when I see these people on
600-pound life and this kid weighed over
800 pounds the EMT workers they have to
pick him up just like 10 of them and I'm
like who's paying for doesn't even sound
like enough yeah it's crazy they carry
him out on like a sheep what's this you
guys you want to take Jason jamei lift
him on his sheet so we thought we'd roll
Jason to see if we can actually roll him
over because he's so obese I grew up on
a farm and we used to have hogs and you
would have to like get them up I don't
even understand what you want to do to
Jason well we want to see how difficult
it is because these EMT workers have to
carry these people so we want to see how
difficult are you gonna carry him no
he's gonna lay on his back wait yeah
we're gonna get on one side and see how
far we can roll him all right I mean I
watch that are you gonna put something
under him Jason get on that Gail let me
see what you exactly way that's me this
guy I loved his suspenders he's wearing
suspenders now because you can't wear a
belt looks like he looks like wimpy from
pop Pop's those suspenders your only 303
come on right three oh three oh three
microphone no different hard to roll
over though all right I'll do with a
play-by-play salan Richard are walking
over to Jason's Jason's laying on the
floor he weighs 303 pounds two guys can
they roll Jason we're simulating this on
my ass I'm on your back is that true
Danny trying
oh my god how could a nurse do this was
it really that hard space was beet red
so this was beet red - that's not easy I
didn't I thought you guys were maybe
kidding oh it was hard my leg in two so
what did we just prove wait a second
wasn't it time what did we just prove
that two healthy men have a lot of
difficulty turning over a 300-pound man
and imagine if he was six hundred are
you able it would be
you